Vous êtes nuls en physique? Vous vous trompez
tout le temps quand vous faites des calculs?
Et bien, ce que je vais vous raconter
aujourd'hui devrait vous rassurer.
On va parler de la plus grosse erreur de
toute l'histoire de la physique.
Elle concerne l'expansion de l'univers et vous
allez voir qu'elle est vraiment grosse.
C'est quelque chose dont vous avez
forcément déjà entendu parler,
on vit dans un univers qui est en expansion.
C'est-à-dire que toutes les galaxies
s'éloignent les unes des autres.
Ça on le sait pour deux très bonnes
raisons, comme souvent en physique,
la première c'est qu'on peut l'observer et
la deuxième c'est qu'on peut le calculer.
Les observations ont été faites pour
la première fois dans les années 30
par l'astronome américain Edwin Hubble.
Vous savez c'est celui qui a, bien plus
tard, laissé son nom au télescope spatial.
Alors à l'époque, Hubble n'avait pas de
télescope spatial mais il a été le premier
à pouvoir observer le mouvement des galaxies
et à se rendre compte que toutes les galaxies
s'éloignaient les unes des autres
et qu'elles s'éloignaient d'autant plus
vite qu'elles étaient distantes.
Ce phénomène d'éloignement est à l'origine
de l'idée de l'expansion de l'univers
et je vous ai dit qu'on ne l'observe pas
seulement mais qu'on peut aussi le calculer.
Pour faire ça on utilise les équations
d'Einstein de la relativité générale
et on les applique au cas de
l'univers dans son ensemble.
Ces équations permettent de calculer à
quelle vitesse les galaxies s'éloignent
et elles sont en parfait accord avec ce qu'observait
Hubble puisqu'elles disent que les galaxies
s'éloignent avec une vitesse qui est
proportionnelle à leur distance.
Alors il faut quand même raconter quelque
chose à propos l'expansion de l'univers.
Vous savez, on présente souvent Einstein
comme le type qui avait toujours raison
qui ne s'est jamais trompé etc...
Et bien s'il y a un point sur lequel Einstein
c'est bien planté, c'est l'expansion de l'univers.
Plusieurs années avant les observations de
Hubble, Einstein s'était déjà rendu compte
que ses propres équations pouvaient conduire à
l'idée d'un univers qui ne soit pas statique.
C'est-à-dire qui soit éventuellement
en expansion ou en contraction.
Et ça pour lui c'était un truc totalement inconcevable
donc il s'est dit que sa théorie était forcément
fausse et il a cherché à modifier ses équations
pour qu'elles puissent donner
un univers qui soit statique.
Alors qu'est-ce qu'il a fait?
Il a rajouté un terme à ses équations
et en fait ça c'était une connerie
parce que ça ne marchait même pas.
Quelques années plus tard, une fois que les
observations de Hubble ont été bien établies,
il a dû reconnaître qu'il s'était planté,
il a accepté l'expansion de l'univers
et il a supprimé le terme supplémentaire
qu'il avait ajouté.
Et même un peu plus tard il a appelé
ça: la plus grosse erreur de sa vie.
Alors maintenant qu'on sait que l'univers est
en expansion, une question qu'on peut se poser,
c'est: Est-ce que ça va durer encore longtemps?
Est-ce que ça va continuer comme ça?
Est-ce que ça va s'arrêter à un moment donné?
Pour essayer de répondre à cette question
on peut utiliser les équations d'Einstein
et ce que nous disent ces équations, c'est que
l'expansion de l'univers ne peut que décélérer.
Alors il y a quand même deux cas de figure possibles:
soit elle va décélérer suffisamment jusqu'à
s'arrêter puis repartir en arrière.
C'est-à-dire que l'univers va se mettre à se contracter
et qu'il va finir dans ce qu'on appelle parfois
un Big Crunch, par opposition au Big Bang.
Soit l'expansion va ralentir mais
continuer éternellement
de plus en plus lentement mais sans jamais s'inverser
et l'univers va devenir de moins en
moins dense et de plus en plus froid.
Ça c'est le scénario qu'on appelle parfois
le Big Chill, le grand refroidissement.
Alors même si tout ça n'aura lieu que
dans plusieurs milliards d'années,
on a quand même envie de savoir dans
laquelle des deux situations on se trouve.
Est-ce qu'on va finir en Big Crunch ou
est-ce qu'on va finir en Big Chill?
En fait pour savoir ça, il faut connaître
la densité moyenne de l'univers.
Si on est au-dessus d'une certaine
valeur, ce sera un Big Crunch
et en dessous ce sera un Big Chill.
Et ce qu'il y a d'étonnant, c'est que chaque fois
qu'on a des observations astrophysiques
qui nous permettent de mesurer la densité de l'univers,
on s'aperçoit qu'on est à chaque fois
à la limite entre les deux scénarios.
Un coup un petit peu au-dessus,
un coup un petit peu en dessous.
Enfin ça, c'était avant 1997,
parce qu'en 1997 a eu lieu une
observation extraordinaire
qui a complètement changé la donne.
Alors qu'est-ce qu'il s'est passé en 97?
Il y a deux équipes d'astronomes qui, indépendamment,
ont fait une observation incroyable.
Ils ont mesuré que l'expansion de l'univers
était en fait en train de s'accélérer.
C'est-à-dire qu'on n'est dans aucun des
deux scénarios que je vous ai décrits,
mais on est dans un troisième scénario
qui est plutôt comme ça:
Donc ça, c'est assez bizarre puisque
je vous ai dit tout à l'heure que
d'après les équations d'Einstein, l'expansion
de l'univers ne peut que décélérer
et là on a des observations qui nous disent
qu'en fait elle est en train de s'accélérer.
Alors comment c'est possible?
En fait c'est possible d'expliquer
ça avec les équations d'Einstein
à une condition, c'est de rajouter ce
fameux terme qu'Einstein avait introduit
et qu'il avait fini par supprimer en disant
que c'était la plus grande erreur de sa vie,
ce terme qu'on appelle la constante cosmologique.
Et si on ajoute ce terme aux équations d'Einstein,
ça colle parfaitement avec les observations
d'un univers en expansion accélérée.
Alors si on est vraiment dans ce cas
de figure, le destin de l'univers
n'est pas vraiment meilleur que dans les autres cas
puisque l'univers va continuer à
s'étendre de plus en plus vite
et il va finir dans ce qu'on appelle
parfois le Big Rip, le grand déchirement.
Cette modification qu'Einstein avait
introduite dans ses équations
et qu'il avait fini par supprimer en disant que
c'était la plus grande erreur de sa vie,
finalement, elle va être indispensable pour
expliquer l'expansion accélérée de l'univers
donc ça vaut le coup de se pencher
un petit peu plus sur ce terme.
C'est donc quelque chose qu'on appelle
la constante cosmologique
et une manière de l'interpréter c'est de
dire que le vide possède une énergie.
Je suis d'accord, c'est un petit peu
contre-intuitif parce que à priori,
le vide, c'est le vide donc on ne voit pas
très bien pourquoi il aurait une énergie
mais bon, c'est quelque chose qu'on observe
expérimentalement, donc à la limite, pourquoi pas?
Et grâce aux observations astrophysiques on peut
même calculer la valeur de l'énergie du vide
et on trouve que cette énergie du vide elle vaut environ
10 puissance -13 joules par centimètre cube.
Alors à la limite, je veux bien admettre
que le vide possède une énergie,
si c'est une idée qui colle avec les
observations astrophysiques, pourquoi pas.
Mais il y a quand même quelque chose de
pas très satisfaisant dans cette idée,
c'est: cette énergie, d'où est-ce qu'elle vient?
Or, il se trouve qu'il y a une théorie qui a
une réponse toute prête à cette question
et cette théorie c'est la mécanique quantique.
La mécanique quantique c'est la
théorie qui permet de décrire
le comportement des particules
au niveau microscopique
et il y a une idée qui est absolument
centrale en mécanique quantique
c'est ce qu'on appelle le principe
d'incertitude de Heisenberg.
Ce principe vous en avez peut-être
déjà entendu parler,
il dit qu'une particule au niveau microscopique
ne peut pas avoir à la fois une position
et une vitesse parfaitement définies.
Et une des conséquences du principe
d'incertitude de Heisenberg,
c'est que les particules ne peuvent jamais
avoir une énergie qui soit complètement nulle,
il y a toujours un petit quelque chose
qui reste, un petit minimum d'énergie.
Ce principe s'applique aussi aux champs
électromagnétiques et une des conséquences de ça,
c'est que le vide n'est jamais vide, il
y a toujours un tout petit peu d'énergie,
associé à un tout petit peu de
champ électromagnétique.
Donc en mécanique quantique, le
vide possède une énergie.
Est-ce que ce n'est pas formidable ça?
On observe l'energie du vide en cosmologie
à travers l'expansion accélérée de l'univers
et la mécanique quantique nous permet d'expliquer
d'où vient cette énergie au niveau microscopique.
Le problème c'est que, si on fait le calcul de la valeur
de l'énergie du vide en mécanique quantique.
Ce qu'on trouve c'est, 10 puissance 107 joules
par centimètre cube, une valeur monstrueuse.
Et je vous rappelle, tout à l'heure on a
dit que la valeur observée expérimentalement
grâce à l'expansion de l'univers c'était
10 puissance -13 joules par centimètre cube
Ça veut dire que la valeur trouvée
par la mécanique quantique
est 10 puissance 120 fois trop grosse,
c'est-à-dire mille milliards de
milliards de milliards de milliards de
fois trop grosse.
Je pense qu'on peut dire sans problème
qu'il s'agit de la plus grosse erreur de
prédiction de toute l'histoire des sciences.
Alors là, vous vous attendez certainement à ce
que je vous explique qu'on a facilement trouvé
d'où vient cette incohérence et que les
chercheurs ont résolu le problème.
Et bien, non, personne n'en sait rien.
Et sachez que c'est même un des problèmes les plus
cruciaux aujourd'hui, en physique fondamentale,
d'expliquer pourquoi l'énergie du vide observée
expérimentalement en cosmologie est aussi petite,
alors que le calcul théorique en
mécanique quantique est aussi gros.
Et pour répondre à cette question vous
voyez qu'il faut manier à la fois
l'infiniment grand et l'infiniment petit, unifier
mécanique quantique et relativité générale.
Donc pour répondre correctement à
cette question il est vraisemblable
qu'il faille disposer d'une théorie du tout
et aujourd'hui, on la cherche toujours.
Merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo.
J'espère que vous ne commettrez
jamais d'erreur aussi grosse.
N'hésitez pas à partager la vidéo pour
m'aider à faire connaitre la chaîne.
Vous pouvez aussi aller voir mes vidéos précédentes,
notamment celle sur Stephen Hawking
et celle sur la théorie des cordes.
Vous pouvez me retrouver
sur Facebook, sur Twitter
et sur mon blog qui s'appelle "Science Étonnante".
Merci et à bientôt!
Sous-titres: Warteks